all predictions
pointed to them winning more of the vote
but exit polls in the netherlands are
indicating that gattvilda's right-wing
freedom party won
five percent less than in the last
european election
wilder's tried to offer some
explanations
naturally it is because of the low voter
turnout
just 37 went out to vote
that means that this country is far from
being pro-european
now vendors is hoping that right-wing
politicians elsewhere will make up the
difference
he has already formed a union with the
leader of the french national front
marine le pen
their plan is to weaken the eu from
within
in voting an island right-wing
politicians have not played a notable
role
the left-wing alliance in fane is
expected to make clear gains
a message more for the national
government than the technocrats in
brussels
but in the czech republic the problem
seems to be indifference
polls show some 80 percent of the
population are not
interested in the elections politicians
on the other hand are
38 parties are standing including a
group promising to improve conditions
for the socially disadvantaged roma
the official results will not be known
until sunday evening
when voters in all the eu's member
states have gone to the polls